okay we ran out of time and I'm before I
get to these cards I want to say we have
two British people here today and I
wanted to ask about the scandal with
David Cameron uh you were getting to
really yes
have you heard about it was at large
Ashcroft is a billionaire gave a lot of
money the Tories I assume he's somewhat
like a British Koch brothers I said he
pays no tax in England
just like the Koch brothers yeah he pays
no tax no types well they gave a lot of
money to the Conservative Party and then
he was very pissed off very personal and
he was not really made a major figure of
it and he apparently has gotten back at
them by writing this memoir where he
says the current Prime Minister the
conservative David Cameron when he was
at Oxford engaged in marijuana smoking
some kind of weird sex parties and I
guess as a hazing ritual put his penis
in the mouth of a pig liping no I did
that they're dead pigs it's a female pig
there's nothing basically wrong with
Cameron exactly ever I don't know what
the problem but I'm Cambridge we did it
with sheep really so this is not unusual
or to British people this wouldn't sound
weird
explain what actually seems weird about
it to you well I mean putting your penis
in the mouth of a dead pig I was not a
part of a fraternity system well I have
to say that from my point of view the
thought of putting my penis in a dead
pig is impossible because I don't have
one you know you know it's kind of funny
though the fact that it was a dead pig
doesn't make it sound any better yeah
Sasa but not bad yeah some British are
different aren't they yeah they just are
I know but there's been so many
pedophilia scandals lately with people
in show business and power and and you
know here we just keep it to the church
over the progress let's get to the
question Ron Reagan what explains the
Republicans obsession with your father
well he's better than Nixon I guess if
you don't have a son who else do they
have really but it's through every
election cycle how they trot him out
again he's like a fetish object they've
all got a stroke the Gipper yeah yeah
hmm stroke the Rani there and then that
of course the question arises as to
whether he would be welcome in today's
Republican Party I think you can look at
the record when he was governor of
California sidled liberal abortion law
as president he raised taxes after
cutting them when he found out the
raising their having I didn't really
work amnesty for 3 million immigrants
offered to get our nukes down to nothing
with garbage yeah yeah 200 Marines
killed in an Lebanon and the barracks
bombing he did not go to war in Iraq
Iran ran out there sit up there and when
a nose
hole opens up over South Pole due to our
putting chlorofluorocarbons into the
atmosphere that was a refrigerant of
course right he did not decide that this
was a liberal hoax designed to deprive
us of cold beer right he he actually did
something about it right you know
encouraged everybody else do so too so
on that basis I forgot I have liberal
Ronald yes sir yeah well I mean he also
said Medicare was socialism that would
rob bats are frail he had on them yeah
but that means that the dear departed
Scott Walker who is talking about I mean
this guy loves Ronald Reagan to the
point of you talk about a fetish he and
his wife purposely got married on
Reagan's birthday isn't that it is so so
it's like single white female with a
dead guy they they like have parties on
his birthday with the eat his favorite
food yet is so creepy
he had his picture in a storage world I
know it must make you as but yeah no I
want to page yeah you need to get this
man a shower okay if we're you go on
about a guy just putting a penis
exactly you're right priorities John if
Bernie Sanders wins New Hampshire does
that unseat Hillary as the presumptive
Democratic nominee no from the next
state spike what is the best green car
out there right now good oh wow that's a
good question is because diesel is now
falling apart that's you know
Volkswagens gonna stay in business but
diesel may not just because what's just
happened because these cars are all
diesel but that they were these are only
diesel diesel cars and they're 11
million of them there were eight hundred
thousand I think a 500 thousand here in
the United States but these only cars
made from 2009 to 2050 so ignorant about
cars and so behind on this stuff that I
would never bought a diesel car because
I associate diesel still with the dirt
it's like the trifecta with the big head
that's it when I think of this diesel
but what they were selling apparently it
was it was right what they were selling
clean diesel it's like when they said
clean coal it never existed they just
saw the words together clean oh they do
exist what go there is clean diesel
there's a substance you put in the
diesel engine called urea which is also
what's in urine it's the same they can
synthesize it so it's literally a piss
injection engine and this car didn't
have it and everybody wondered well how
did they do it how did they do it
without the urea and and they did not so
but it here's what I would say the
biggest winners can't wait no I feel
like you left here learning something
yeah I never knew this about just saw so
much better than telling me
here's what I would say though the big
winner in the scandal is our old friend
the Prius or even though you know it's
been around for long if it car it's been
around forever electric cars are going
to do well because of this Tesla and
everything else and then the Germans are
coming with their electric cars in 2018
so there's their comeback maybe okay
Jane what ways can the average person
get involved in animal conservation oh
there's so many ways but the way I'm
advocating is we have a program for
young people we can fight and struggle
and work to save animals to save
environments but if the new generations
coming up on going to be better stewards
than we are what's the point so we have
this program Roots & Shoots it's now in
140 countries
Roots & Shoots Roots & Shoots and choose
imagine a big tree yes think how it
begins a little tiny seed little tiny
roots and shoots appear but the magic in
that seed is so powerful that those
little roots to reach the water can work
through rocks and brushing aside that
little chute to reach the sunlight can
go through cracks in a brick wall and
knock it down hundreds and thousands of
young people of all ages around the
world
choosing projects to make the world a
better place rolling up their sleeves
being empowered to take action that's
what gives me the most hope
comparative animals because what we need
to realize is that animals like us have
personalities they have feelings
happiness sadness fear despair and we
should respect
sometimes our penises in their mouths
listen I challenge you will you put your
penis in the mouth of a dead no ma'am
orangutan damn I'm an American John what
can you tell us about your new show with
Eric Idle oh that's gonna be awesome
nothing now why did you choose Eric as
opposed to the other remaining I liked
him
marginally better than the other and
he's also very good at music right so we
need a little bit of song always look on
the bright side of life and we're gonna
trot it out in Florida because in
Florida if we if we bomb nobody will
know right
so don't they well I mean you guys are
big whatever you do don't know no no no
no if we fail in Saratoga
no no Sarasota yeah I played there
believe me
it's a really nothing survive it anyhow
ever read any any any newspapers about a
bear review of the Sarasota bugle you go
no I think you're right for estimating
how anticipated this show is sir yeah
well it's not it's not very good
borrowing expectation this is no I'm
just telling the truth
I'm bored with all the [ __ ]
it's not a very good church it's it's
what we call sit-down comedy is it is it
new material um well the materials from
about 1967 it's not new but it's not
well-known +44 I think you're being very
modest because you and everybody's
charming are they letter from a huge
star u2 or the Lennon and McCartney of
comedy and I would buy would walk about
a thousand miles all right we gotta go
thank you very much everybody
Oh
you